[Music]
whoa what's up with the slaves yeah a
little bit of a teaser right there hi
hello welcome to a special Friday night
livestream here at gamespot.com
yes youtube.com slash games spot been
Janka michael hi I'm soon-to-be jean-luc
psyche in this seat right here we have a
special thing for all of you folks out
there because we're playing granblue
fantasy versus the fighting game for the
grand Bleu franchise the closed public
beta has just gone live for its second
online session so we figured that
instead of just playing it we'll play it
for all you fine folk out there now the
lobby's is filling blows in transition
yo Luke I love we were thinking about
maybe doing a community Fridays ish
thing but you know it's a little
complicated cuz we weren't sure what the
beta was gonna consist of but it turns
out we could probably link up but this
Lobby is for this web from zero to a
hundred real quick yeah did Oh button we
can't connect oh speaking of the man
who's running the stream all by himself
and getting on the stream to jean-luc
sup man it's Friday I hear so where we
are we are turned it is 6 p.m. on a
Friday I can Sophos because everyone's
gone home the top of the game is
reminding me actually there's still a
lot of people here yeah yeah a lot of
people are out there playing rocket
League having fun but we're over here
playing Graham blue having fun we're
about to have fun we're trying to have
fun try to have fun I'm trying to fight
this chocolate chocolate I do I do right
here I turned it up is my second
but uh but they're not she's not letting
us kill maybe the dad dad don't do that
to me boy this is you keep trying we'll
just wait I might just jump to a
different console so maybe I just can't
connect with this person maybe that's
that's a just can't connect connect Oh
Chuck chocolates right there in the chat
there there little boy sitting here what
trying to fight with a student that is
perfect
Hey Dude choco blows on it let's say
thank you I'm trying we've been trying
for a while
oh [ __ ] connecting wait connect Renaud
it's a sick acting you know
is this like the typical bass nonsense
this is a beta test it's a I don't know
if it's actually been labeled as a
stress test I haven't looked at enough
but like open from like our options were
either 2:00 in the morning to 7:00 a.m.
or 6:00 at night to 11 oh yeah this is
the this is the second session so this
Lobby is full yeah we we you hopped in
here and there was like seven people
yeah like in a minute and filled up to
64 chocolate boy will want to fight you
that is that is weird maybe this council
was just not good maybe this is uh ready
ready press X ready press ready again
it's okay I expect someone else to
happen during yeah yeah switch seats I'm
gonna go over here you go over there
john-boy wants their seats all Goku's
here go to Goku Goku so no what's up
sorry hey you don't have to apologize we
understand it's all good
yeah let's switch seats yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah cool cool I like this Oh see
if this works
ready up radio Radio me maybe maybe me
I'm really excited to like finally play
this game uh-huh
I don't know anything about it no
nothing about granblue at all no all
right all right well yeah let's listen I
want to burst out there if there any
grand blue fans out there in the chat
sorry we this is our first introduction
to Graham blue like an experiential
sense yes because we have not played the
mobile game I'm sure it's fine there's a
lotta a lot of big names who have worked
on Graham blue fantasy but this is our
first foray into Graham blue we're video
games yeah we're using the the anime
fighter love that we have to kind of
help us go in yeah yeah we are expert
anime fighters and we figured that know
what that this art arcs this is going
all in on this must be for a reason yeah
right okay looking forward for you to
start the same thing if this one here
let's let's actually I don't want to do
this but what if we switched lobbies
talkable you want to follow us what if
what if we just switch lobbies right one
day someone's name is Miko one day less
[ __ ] dull maybe a song Tom ba ba ba
po Pipo and [ __ ] like that [ __ ] bang I'm
pouring in
okay cool and Miku Mondays yeah maybe
special lobbies
he's got anything you can talk to you to
switch lobbies there's no mr. tartar
prison
maybe I just gotta back out oh here's
let's let's go let's go to one that's a
band I talked about will let you know
where we where we Larry and um I'm sure
you're watching the stream poletik will
let you know it to make sure that we get
a fight in because we appreciate you
trying to seek us out
you're probably gonna whoop our ass go
to lobby 15 that's like a fool you've
seen you think like 29 so you're gonna
mount I wanted it I feel like I feel
like we need to oh you want to go like
maybe 11 that 11 sounds good yeah love
Bobby 20 okay
lobby 20 hit us up in the lobby 20 so
it's good to have some people there but
yeah hmm oh man yeah
arts and arts this upcoming fighting
game so we know we're gonna give a
little love to it see what's up with it
know again like you said we don't know
much about granblue but we do want to
like arts games yeah and we do like
animals like that they put this like
sign in book but you can put any
messages you want no problem alright
chocolate boys followed us to the lobby
so over here sit in the same seats work
yeah pick chocolate did you there the
following us through and we go to the
other side I mean do they have to be is
that how it works yeah cuz of them if
you see the mats Oh ready we can come on
again this is a closed beta test so
there might be technical difficulties
but connecting okay good that's what
steps are happening
waiting for it any moment now
no any moment sick
I like this airship it reminds me guys
working skies because it's a I'm really
really done with that yeah come on
Graham blue don't fail us now
Oh will Potter seduce ya GameSpot's
number-one fan will parlour boy yeah
we'll say ready again why are we dude
wait what if it's what if he has to do
with her now what if her Nats mr.
shouldn't we've never had a net problem
with Bart's his games has that's never
in here I've never had to shoot you
stuff in here yeah
you know you lease Afghan law
see oh we got that we had some like
daytime regulars Jessie Jonathan Mattel
a in the chaps up man
so I've got Dan I see ya wheel Potter's
dry-firing Joyce in the chat you know
you say yeah the avatars big fan
yeah got pretty cool jewel parts up
thanks Rhonda see ya
look the avatars are cute at least yeah
I mean all the Arts is La Vie bass games
always have really cute avatars I hate
to do this do we want to try finding
someone who that isn't chocolate boy you
could try mixing it up well we'll see
what happens
yeah maybe we'll try and get around and
see uh stand up here fighting souther
all these on the cabinets on the tile
wow these are the captains quarters
cabinets hidden away this is open beta
no it's closed closed beta sorry about
that it is public but it's all raven
night raven I'm on it
all right let's see let's go my favorite
team diamond yeah chocolate boy maybe we
could try a little later yeah yeah it's
got a few matches in yeah I'm trying to
figure out what the issue is yeah I
wanna I want to punch some people what I
want to do want to swing some swords
yeah yeah yeah we're gonna be going for
about an hour at least
so there's time there's time sewer I see
our feelin come on ideal I feel the
connection happening it's it's live I
really hope I really hope it's not us
it's not you it's me
that's how it goes no no this is the
gamble you always get when you check our
closed beta no frills anytime anytime
there's a beta yeah
[Music]
we were able to get final fan of Final
Fantasy well let's get a Follis on a
sixth-grader
lower twice that's true for one three
hours eight hours of peace or eight
hours together
yeah that's a lot that was yeah you guys
each did four hours I didn't you didn't
eight hours eight hours night life Joker
we can't download this no you think you
need to have been signed up a little
while back and gotten a key for it
mmm-hmm so yeah cuz it's not it it's not
again
it's not open it worked fine this
morning yeah chocolate bar you have an
issues with other people like not just
us
I'm curious if you're having trouble
with other people
try workshop if this is uh this us or if
this is like this is the game they uh I
I'm going to believe that it's probably
the game
bad man anyway this might just be a
really cool hangout lobby stream hey
worst case we have so much animation
[ __ ] [ __ ] we do is true more if
we could actually open this up to a Q&A
in the chat yeah chocolate boy Sam
they're having similar issues so it's
not us it is unfortunately the beta let
me let me check in with my boy
sonic Fox real quick cuz he said they
see what he is doing he said he was
jumping into the grand buddha fantasy
can find him that's what I've been
saying I'm listening let's find out
where sonic boxes and try to line up at
his cat was right a stream let's not
read the streaming box in the GameSpot
office that's a good that's my goal I
want to do the whole yeah we have them
on for community Friday heck yeah we'll
get your ass whooped by sonic Fox
I remember after after Eva last year you
and cally were like dude we gotta get
sonic rocks on we got a little yadi in
the plane just see a thieves that'd be
cool boat on a little boat I'm doubt
that let me just go onto his Twitter
chokolate voices he got on gob oh man
maybe maybe it's help it's not there are
more people who just joined the server
though like this lobby just filled up
like when I blinked yeah maybe maybe the
servers are kind of leveling out come on
come on I'm ready for it
the connections popped up it was us I'm
gonna be so mad
let's go
the people are saying they're getting in
why we did it all right so now we can
start fighting with our friends yes I
like it
we'll see let's see how this one goes
first a range that's grannies blue
Catalina oh wait this actually isn't a
yeah
gran is blue and Catalina looks like
she'd be best girl I don't know about
that's why I picked her pre-emptive yeah
about them if they're any grand blue
fans in the chat let us know let like
lay it down on us let us know what's
good
oh love the our stop man so much man
this is all you because that loves
guilty gear xrd and the city's four
lines drawn it's yeah the the 3d
elements like guilty here like jack ball
fighters Oh believe it Childress oh I
love and believe in victory I mean we've
been seeing all those rumors but persona
5 in this art
[Music]
looks like these are very first man
playing night is every fancy person
battle to engage cold presentations very
good yeah I know we saw
where is it
it looks like gran has some stuff
I got taken to the core God God God God
sorry it's all get hella got lose thank
you thanks for open our ass that's cool
sick for any RPG on ps4 let's keep it
going yeah let's keep the fights going
on try different character
someone came I ate my hands on as many
people yeah yeah we strived on let's try
it sir Lancelot's so he's got going on
Sir Lancelot
I like big fights in a cab Oh get it
what kill it's putting in like she
fighter yes it is a fighting game it is
a fighting ass game let's see okay oh I
think I'm on monkey I'm gonna try and
keep up with chat while Ben tries to
keep up with fights and Jean look I need
you to shout cast alright cool man cool
you would want me to yeah okay kept
Persian here oh yeah that's a
professional shot oh you've been Viktor
that was definitely Capcom 3 now she's
our coach yeah that's cool
ok says okay Lancelot is like a rogue
and that's America
okay okay that's a super yeah I did so
here somebody says Bureau's best barrel
that's it
all right so we'll find figure that shop
Dan this looks at this look fair yes
we'll is that is that a British thing
well a bit yeah that's a bit
I like that I'm taking a nap okay
Catalina's Best Pop solo
that's Mizzou
yeah we got this is yes it does
yes there's no way yeah okay
plants illogical softscape I don't know
like does have something in a
personality type where design-wise I
feel like an archetype yeah it looks
like you betray yeah I'm getting this
I'm Naruto wait Oh grannies Naruto yeah
so Catalina's like would she not we are
the power-ups on the stage
[Music]
[Music]
y'all yeah if anyone knows how to
activate yours
to beta Y Midwest so our time which is
211 405
so yeah you got 8-series fate oh yeah
yeah yeah I mean I know about fit I know
I'm not big into it but I am well answer
is in a fighting game night Metro
boosters oh yeah go blasters nitro
blasters metrobüs blasters which is like
a fighting game where all of the
characters are visual novel character is
sick and some people talk about our ace
fate it's originally a visual novel I
believe there's so many people in these
chairs well answer isn't that snail
Fight Night Live Joker who we playing as
we're plan is we're trying everybody try
everyone we played Grand we played
Catalina
we didn't play gran yet I'm seeing oh we
see gran yeah so we play Catalina and we
play a Lancelot
I picked ferry just now okay a cool cool
cool cool cool cool cool cool
stormy says let's go last life saucy
okay now you can let that one comment
that oh yeah of course
yeah these graphics are rubbish in Thank
You quiso be yeah we're gonna let them
we need we need to update the
[Music]
we were playing so I was streamers that
are allowed yeah I was streaming void
bastards the other day so everyone who's
cuz there's so many people in the chat
it's like what game is this what game is
this and people kept saying boy bastards
but to be fair like but yeah and in what
way would bastards be used in a like
being a yeah but if out if internet
[ __ ] wouldn't use that word or shoe
that's not like that is that is
something that's like what do you think
it picks up like most of the word or
like just come for parole because I get
like plural maybe like like what if I
says bastard sword which is a weapon and
final a [ __ ] castle it's just a web
plane and have any urban
give me like that it's him see grandma
fancy relink JRPG will be epic that is
support was was originally a
PlatinumGames join right what do you
always telling me jade was telling us of
all people yeah
Jacob Decker the one of the top level
weaves here top level anime fan yeah oh
no we're double faring it is very and
buried Oh fairy is a is a me Cote from
Final Fantasy oh the cat person
I I just sit there and think about that
for a second got some good jams - seems
like it
we could turn it up great yeah as our
style sana pity but the run colors
definitely bad
but Leo never got the anime waifu's yeah
Faria looks like she's fit to like like
naughty not willpotter spiffy like like
small like she don't know what caused it
but this week I feel like there's been
way more talks about I think it's my
bowl and my kazoo oh like a baby when I
started I think it start with my tweet
well maybe it start with you treated
I'll start with I remember tomorrow is
talking about he's been watching full
monoculars brother oh yeah and I was
talking about how I've been watching the
original series and my girlfriend in the
middle like an anime conversation and
then even the super is talking more
about anime yeah
oh yeah over there that's the corner so
down with that
[Music]
[Music]
yes
so you're all hey I'm thinking like
Japan time sailing time
[Music]
but it's like 300 ever
let me catch up on the chat real quick
oh damn this monster huh I don't know if
she's the character for me but also if
so folks in the chat hit us with that
grand balloon knowledge but also if you
could play in this beta let us know
about the character types cuz we're
still trying to figure that out
again this is the second run of oh yeah
foreign fighters so this is our second
run of the closed beta but we didn't get
a chance to play a first run because
that was like Who I am
yeah that [ __ ] ended at seven eight yeah
that was not absolutely for other time
zones I'm still suing him I'm gonna go
with grand let's see what he's got going
on Grand Slam
alright is this from Arc System Works
yes yes Leslie lie yes this is an arc
disjoint oh you already had that
answered okay graphics are yeah grabs
your you scroll up in the chat
yeah I'm sure I'm trying to catch up
trying to catch up uh yeah like BlazBlue
gets to gear dragon ball yeah
when does this game come out ooh that's
a good ask question I don't know I would
assume this year I hope there's a beta
like this I would assume this year
that's not the demo for Samurai Shodown
come out that King comes out like right
after yeah right people yeah because it
has to be there's a I know that like for
game releases slash new character
updates there is a like a limit first
for them to be like oh you know like if
a character comes out like a character
can't come out a week before it would be
like you can't play that Korea has to be
like I'm different builds of it yeah
let's be like a month or month and a
half in advance so I'm like that could
bring us bring us current really yeah
why do you bring us current on the
office look trying to read I want to
keep up with them I don't know if it's
PlayStation Plus they made a PS Plus
only
my stuff's always weird where it's like
city commit bullets sometimes like I
think picnics format you can play the
fifth cross just like that
like other things you have to play with
I don't get it it's kind of weird
also I heard they're upping the price up
here's one six or nine you don't really
say yet
[Music]
it's not banana leaf right Alyssa
paradise Apsaras ear - sorry
[Music]
yeah it feels kind of right yeah it
looks like is it more would you say it's
more in line with like tonight is like
the Street Fighter of anime but good
other night I still like I got I can
move up down - back and forth - you're
like God yeah come ability engage I
don't know
I think sigh games picked it up sigh
games original evolved
oh they're making I think that's
collapse that's laughs I because sigh
Kingsley partnership yeah
is right I even but give my head I'm
like I bet you couldn't but the idea of
a mobile studio
a big old grin then they couldn't do it
that just seems like oh that'd be like a
pretty big undertake grin is definitely
more of like he's hi I'm gonna be
pleased
you know economy he's the Ratner he's
the sole bad guys please this event
he's the Goku of twenty goki
[Music]
properly
[Music]
[Music]
I'm going with all that like oh she
cried yeah oh yeah that that's all like
stuff that's in play for or in place for
her free to play yeah but it's still not
free to play and I'm like it's really
weird so main question for me and this
is how many characters are there there's
six playable right there six six
playable nope but I like how many are
gonna be there in the end what do you
consider like a a good boss so I feel
like this this games got to have like a
bigger roster just people definitely
bigger than six because of the fact that
it's a game based on like a got your
thing where it's like oh let's just have
a whole bunch of design characters that
are really good right
like having not all those characters in
that game is gonna make someone who's a
fan of this up like upset oh I'm sure
they'll be I mean it's just a closed
beta again so this probably definitely
limited but like well I mean like in the
in the phone yeah like what do you
consider like a solid like number of
turn to roster I mean for me I like like
20-ish funny-ish okay yeah like 59
versus a decent base roster yeah snap
there's a really good $30 not sixty well
I mean we don't know you know they might
have like a story mode and all this
other stuff yeah again we're this is
still just a public beta test so not
sure exactly what the final final
product will look like
or characters some cool challenges you
know I'm saying here so I paid like $40
400 me twice I don't feel bad about that
believe in victory wait you mean like
you're watching the game cross stream
doing we don't we don't we never look at
the challenge because every time I was
like yeah one time yeah sorry
yeah we just monitor the YouTube chat
that is something I'd like to I think on
the back end we're gonna house
[Music]
but hopefully that means like I would
like really we're fighting I said uh oh
hey that's me
I'm on gamespot oh that's what they
mattered okay sorry I thought they meant
would be wrong the game spotlight stream
where are you playing very repetitive
yeah okay that's what we want yeah yeah
oh yeah tomboy tomboy just going fast on
the chat we like to fight did you know
the heck you got this thing rolling okay
sorry is 1g more
[Music]
a way to do it as you've got to do X
version of the movie so that's gonna be
like a wallet if you're close to the
wall I'm slowly figuring this out bang
dude this looks so sharp does
I just want a blaze we've done in the
style I need to raise my skillful moves
average I go dreamer what anime is this
it's not an anime but it is animated
Jason it's definitely anime
it is animate is capital a anime grand
blue grand blue fantasy anyone know any
free games that look like this well I
mean have you heard of grand boubou
fantasy I don't know if it looks exactly
like I don't actually familiar with how
the Hawks yeah we should move to another
lobby is it full it's pretty pretty full
new rumor saying the combo system is
awkward it is kind of weird and I'm
still trying to wrap my mind around yeah
do I want to start passing the
controller yeah it's gonna say do it do
I move to another lobbying we can start
passing the controller Oh talk abou is
still in the chat so let's let's let's
jump lobbies okay I have something to
say say it
daddy's bathroom oh my god I was
actually just about to say I need to use
the bathroom me for oh my god I was
gonna say give the controller to Michael
now I know nothing alright guys I'll be
back at the same time if you really want
to that's fine I thought I would we
would have we wouldn't did she
everything alright well then you go
right now this is just all full I'll be
back
oh my god then get up get in the lobby
because we don't want to I'm done a lot
of them yeah on screen
we've done it dang there's so many
people who have access to this closed
beta wait there's an actual anime for
this as well apparently according to
these jokes the actual anime is called
granblue fantasy it's on crunchyroll and
i think they know shoot alright so we've
we've jumped to lobby 21 yep I'm gonna
take it up here to the cue the captain
squares if there's a cabinet available
up here yeah sit down
hang out angel sonic actually do you
wanna pick your character
I have Catalina yes I just got the okay
this is nicer cuz I just hit the button
I'll I'll pick Grand because like you
said he's kind of the base yeah he gave
me a better idea of like how the game
works
I realize now that the abilities are
activated I think on doing certain
attacks
nice I can see
granblue game dope what platform so
we're playing right now in ps4 I think
it's on ps4
we got switch I see I'm not sure what
performs I know that you can play on ps4
because that's where we are you ready
this console pc come on
oh you abandon the captain's quarters
that other person was not joining I see
haven't watched the anime I just on you
to watch list sitting really interesting
wash I I mean I'm hoping that maybe this
game would get me into it and we go to
this person like Dragon Ball fighters
made me want to watch Dragon Ball again
[Music]
it's real easy for me to get swayed by
anime fighting games
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
play this game it feels amazing I like
it I just wish that they put in a
tutorial they at least kind of explain a
lot of the stuff but I am having a good
time with it and just waiting for peeps
- uh yeah you might have to like search
someone out well I went to this one
where they were sitting down so I
figured it we're good but they might
they might be like they might have also
run to the bath taking it easy this is
no time for bathroom day for everywhere
I'm gonna have this person I'm just
gonna keep hopping a people and
[Music]
hopefully one of them's at their
controller whatever the other grambler
fantasy was being made uh it's like an
RPG right mm-hmm yeah it was made by
platinum and then they dropped it I
don't know all the details but
apparently it's still being made I hope
so it sounds really great I'm not even
into granblue and I'm already excited
for it skin looks gorgeous
it's that it's that that guilty year 2d
3d style that it just looks so great no
matter what I have be honest I can't
hold any more hey hey that's fine do you
think I'll try to find so bad hopefully
I think Benny wants to fight they've
been following us so I'm gonna go over
here Benny if that's if you can hear me
come on come on down let's do a fight Oh
Michaels back number times you realized
ps4 exclusive looks like an action RPG
show log gameplay guilty gear heck yeah
guilty gear
welcome back what up how was your
restroom
[Music]
it is behind yeah so what's been going
on ah so given these we are in the
middle of trying to find our good boy
Benny here oh is Benny in the chat I
think but Benny if you're in the if
you're in the chat you probably can't
tell us now peer about the fight but
when you get the chance let us know
oh shoot I forgot John the switch to
gran Oh down the sky realm adventurer
dude did you do let me just catch up on
what's going on the chat sorry I'm I'm
really out of it it's a Friday night
here the gang squad offices and
everyone's chillings yeah you got some
board games going on in the break room
yeah yeah broccoli going on too and
there's some grand blue Fantasy Versus
going on over here
Oh custom dialogues for character soup
because I'm I notice house now believe
in victory believe and Vic you are good
on the regular I like the red colour
gran-gran red
[Music]
okay that's good
I recommend making this work somehow
[Music]
take it up yeah yeah for you today
it's all good
[Music]
we both have the same idea I didn't like
it some pecan boys yeah so I think it's
it's like out like an organ you can do
like like the three hits into a special
attack and if you do a certain special
attack that kid like something it'll
continue on okay
[Music]
it wasn't exactly a visa that was good
we ready to loosen it's almost like a
this talking about
Oh does a police watch the square
triangle circle
I think it's
thank you got them it was a good fight I
think here you you wanted you were you
were lined up next to God was someone
I'm gonna let you do the the next one
and Benny if you are in the chat let us
know
[Music]
I'll fight Benny nobody - I'm sorry oh
I'm [ __ ] but he said good game he's such
a good sport good game
Oh Jeff ID him again yeah he's just
following you around all the cabinets
you went - oh no
so I was wondering if he's a person in
the chat been in bed a minute you want
to fight again we're do use fight you
thought just but we just want a weak
flame again though that's fine he chased
us around for three cabinets is grandpa
famous in Japan yeah so the boy is here
oh oh yeah yeah there's Benny right
there yeah there's Benny there's
chocolate boy shouts - Benny thank you
for the gun I will fight you
I'll fight you after your your next
soundtrack frightening your next
chocolate pointy rod look boy we're
gonna fight you you bank here since the
beginning and we still haven't fought
you yet yeah well we will get some
matches versus where I left it with
Grandpa gran gran granny blue gran gran
blue Oh gran gran gran gran I was trying
to get into I'll try to find a way to
play gravelly fantasy cause he's a
planing the browser's bankers but really
I could only find the chapters a lot of
the word on the street is because
version
I don't know this is probably one of
those types of things that would
definitely have been very jewelry fan
translational welcome patches gauge the
chuckles
was a
Jeffy's okay I think it's just holding
on to my period I would sit with Jeff
easy from time I was also playing a
samurai shodown
[Music]
really what you can play it locally
because it has training which is nice
player because I swear the demo listen I
still think this is like a network
yeah I'm saying there's an optional
mobile game okay okay how are you
special so it's like a four circles
[Music]
those are the Jackie French motion
I think I was like you
[Applause]
[Music]
so those are first you first met me yeah
Benny ultimate no mercy
[Applause]
so destiny oh that's what they said cool
all right chocolate boy we're cabin area
let's do it that's the same the same
cabinet position the same faded cabinet
that that was here before uh all these
guys I like the I like Catalina's
character design I just don't know how
to play her very Oh chocolate boy I'm
with you we want here you see your
teleportal whoa
the sure conviction now it's time to
throw down rebel one let's rock
you ain't from the Midwest if you've
never seen this before
get ready let's go can't escape from
crossing fate they should have came up
with something like really wild for ya
they've like what the Wheel of Fate is
turning yes I like down
you don't like chocolate boy oh now this
fine this is fine just it says the
swords are crossed on the cabinet so I
think that means it's in it's just
loading you can't escape crossing so
that's that's the only indicator that
I've seen because when you don't have a
match it has the sword straight up right
and if they're cross that means it's
actually going here yeah try to find the
tells trying to try and see what's going
on
we can't be chocolate boy you equip
video games or vs. games yeah we're not
gonna quit I'm gonna tell you something
damn no love y'all I gotta love from the
west coast your boy loses it alot at
fighting games what I haven't stopped
okay looks like it looks like we've
connecting connecting connecting you
should give it a you just say I believe
in it I think we can do it do it there's
good everyone's just concentrated focus
to help us join this fight right now
we can make it happen please you just
gotta believe these chairs make
fantastic noises and I don't know if
they're getting picked up by the
microphones but I hope they are oh oh
man I can't make mine do the sound shoot
the game tonight is our battle yeah for
whatever reason we can't fight younger
boys I can't I'll give it one more try
but if we can't then we might just have
to move on huh then we'll try again
well then we'll try again later we'll
keep trying show the other character see
we switched from Glenn from mine we
switched from Glen to Catalina Glen blue
fantasy yo so we're gonna play Catalina
now yeah we played fairy
we've also played everyone I went
through the whole list okay I'm pretty
sure sip now for this game is whack
can't man it's almost like it's a closed
beta you're not wrong but also that's
kind of associated if anyone can find
out what lobby sonic Fox is hanging out
in we should go try to find here we go
figure out but it's probably full I'm
sure definitely it's definitely again
fortunately she boy is this one that's a
bummer
boy I want to fight you chocolate boy I
can't believe that this game is doing
this in keeping us apart I know it's a
damn shame my visor it's just a beta
this is the beta so yeah we don't know
like what other movie modes there are
anything like that's very typical of
fighting game betas I think this is
actually supposed to be like a stress
test like it's a it's a network only
kind of thing though tiny shiny Penny's
got us on the update said that sonic Fox
to do a set could do seven percent with
fairy off just the grass got a bit of
catching up to do because I don't know
how he could do that with fairy and
that's a
that's a thing hmm I believe though cuz
sonic Fox Thank You chocolate boy you're
wonderful oh yeah thanks for trying
preaching you do like playing fighting
games though I'm pointing at the screen
again I should point it the camera yeah
you should follow the channel because uh
we do know played games laminations to
this person to the shooter mind adjust
and up again we play games online every
Friday most of them are fighting games
as it turns out a lot of them anime
influence because that seems to be a
thing that we really like so if you do
like playing like guilty gear blazblue
any of that stuff cross tag you should
hang out with us you can't even press
that X button press X button for us
channel with awesome stories please
don't leave us be our friends yeah we
appreciate you trying chocolate boy but
yeah if you play any other other old
enemy fighters you know where to find us
you know it's funny games gonna play for
weeks dream yeah usually we would do an
announcement earlier in the week through
the community post yeah we haven't been
very good at that
get it up like Tuesday or Wednesday yeah
and if that isn't the case we'll at
least like if we know ahead of time
we'll say like during one of the shrooms
- Gianluca and I are probably gonna be
on a stream before that true true but
yeah we just love playing fighting games
and it doesn't matter if you're good are
you bad you just want to have a good
time doesn't matter if you're good bad
or ugly you can hang out we can all have
a good time last week we played BlazBlue
cross tag battle for the new spring
update and boy I had a great time with
all of y'all and all of y'all
cuz across tank rentals [ __ ] dough I
love that game so much yeah
she wanted me heck yeah
what what funny games you guys want to
play cuz we're thinking about doing like
a an evil thing maybe where we play like
the top the top games anyway the game
spot Eva hold it the game spot ebo lead
up show where we'll be like ah what
flippin blaze Blues on the main stage
flippin just all them and just run
through that I totally just named only
one cuz I'm what would you say would you
say cross tag okay I'll say okay under
fives on there properly yeah under night
yeah I wanna if y'all ever do committee
phrase for on a night again last year
y'all did commune Friday's for under
night and I was in Germany for that and
I was watching from my hotel room was
that the one where no one joined I think
so yeah ooh
tiny you've got my number under nights
top top right now checking a street
fighter yeah I'm not getting any luck
right now totally these streets right
now they're trying to try anything
cabinets into the Apple is babies doing
things om k 11 we got to bring back they
announced the the DLC coming up for the
hour ago right an hour ago and I I'm
willing to say I think that it confirms
the date of mine leak
and I'm willing to say that that
chainsaw at the end of the trailer was
ash Williams and also Yannick and I
called it longtime Ashley Williams from
Mass Effect that's the one that it's
coming finally we've always wanted
Ashley to be a favorite bag favorite
space racist oh yeah so Mortal Kombat 11
definitely gonna be game even play a lot
more yeah come and run down the road the
only one I can't play it's Tekken
because I'm terrible at what I got it I
gotcha hey if any all know what's up
attacking cool we got in a fight what
haven't I played you in Tekken yet I
don't know I haven't played Tekken since
since Dr I know that's why I never
really played Tekken so like I try and
play it I'm like dude it's like Soul
Calibur but you have to be mindful of
your limbs like that's true yeah
definitely
cuz you you've actually got like the
forward punch back punch all out but I'm
from San Diego so I grew up I actually
grew up playing with SDT San Diego
second so I used to see mark man and
Alex manor by local arcades and I used
to get my eyes on you by those rules
it's now like a marked man you don't
know me no more man
oh it's too good it's too good for the
hood man Victor Nam is getting mark
Catalina might be a guest role right now
for you I know nothing about her
other than she's got I don't fantasy
levels of bellies dishes cowbell stop
belts off belly oh we got a belt for
games just wearing capes
well that might actually be more than
others happy
cabron
[Music]
work that was so fast
you let a little llama though beat your
ass oh no battle to charge
charlotta Charlotte's totally illallah
I didn't play I just pick her at all
maybe we need to pick her if y'all know
Ilana fell in the chat hit us up on old
pros or Excalibur a company that
supports me well what if we did do a
final fantasy xiv stream 2.0 what I was
doing policy I was gonna say we're late
for our storm whoo
I'm done
yeah I really want to do that around one
extra life stop speaking
it's also nice to play
so it's okay you probably got a like a
feel for it it's kind of more it's it's
time I don't want to say like slow and
deliberate like it's a I think it's kind
of slow and deliberate it is like you've
got to be more calculating you got to
think about what you're doing here is a
weird thing
Amy's good fell off those boxes
but dang that is a very big crown this
is true facts mm uh I'm think I'm faded
yeah no I'm just Congrats
Yoshimitsu this is fun that's been
around second it's true yeah yeah I
understand if technically you think that
that's the great thing about doing
community pride A's I'll try our out we
play a lot of play a lot of fighting
games but sometimes we'll play Halo I
tapped on the table and I apologize yeah
Charlotte I gotta get stronger yeah Oh
cubone you have a good jockey ball thank
you for stopping by get it take it easy
have a good weekend yeah it's Friday oh
[ __ ] it's Friday and I still have a [ __ ]
ton of work to do not do you it's more
like so for me just enjoy that weekend
man why you can think and we can see
what could do if you press fast-forward
okay Madison but you're did you already
feel another cup what so I need to take
a weekend because the next weekend ain't
no weekend cuz that's eight three yeah
where we basically this is our last
weekend before we have to work for two
weeks straight yeah like it's feeling it
likes me it's funny I wasn't feeling the
ìiî energy like oh three stole yeah yeah
it's a ways away
we had are like all hands on a three
meeting the second we came back from
that meeting I could feel like the vibe
in the office yeah everyone's like
everyone shift and everyone shifted to
e3 modes you know III stands for uh
Michael that's it's all Electronic
Entertainment Expo [ __ ] I coulda sworn
it was good for so we have we had that
with the All Hands III meetings and give
away company secrets are you yeah
they're like what III actual it stands
and I was like eat eggs every day it is
not letting me hit okay it just takes a
little bit of time you got no patience
from Japan maybe they've got Japanese
characters in the game
Oh No knack three more like snack three
whoa I'm actually really excited about
Microsoft yes same yeah ghostbusters
you'd like yeah we just went through a
we went through a rehearsal of it and
boy howdy do we have some free all like
it's brittle they say every year but
like they said they're having a to our
press conference whoa I mean that makes
sense like I feel like because Sony very
far in advance said we're not gonna need
three and that's Microsoft being like
dude okay it's our time yeah and I
believe in Phil Spencer that that dude
that dude is um yeah what'd he call it
luck
he's uh he's a man of his word yeah
trying to find some maybe this person is
just too far away
I'm yeah so I'm trying to that's kind of
maybe what happened with chocolate boys
you try to fight love muscle excuse yeah
Phil Spencer say we will about Microsoft
Phil Spencer is a good dude though
Spencer is the man
it's really weird hearing people say
Phil Spencer because it makes me think
of the show I did with my roommate
Spencer I'll try this guy yeah he's uh
oh I'm definitely here for an NBC 400
are the rumors of that I hope so
that's what I'm saying sign me up for
that but that that really depends on how
Marvel is a oh wait I was in but I was
actually not you got your seat stole my
seat was stolen I didn't even realize
fight izanagi
izanagi where's where's you now call me
when we want him he should be a get on
which to crossover characters that
gravelly fantasy da little what do we
get some p4a characters we got some
under night carry good crime thank you
should be tight
I have a question with a if they do p5
arena they have to do make it a
crossover game oh that the other persona
games right yeah yeah yeah cuz that's
what p4a was awesome yeah and you can't
do just persona 5 carries I'd be too
small to roster
so you think they would do with four or
you compete with three or makes it both
I do both because they've all got killed
in both but they don't have but I'm
saying this is under the assumption that
they're gonna it's gonna be full 3d so
they have to start from scratch
Oh like even if it's the same right yeah
[Music]
yeah oh that was smooth
you imagine like out like a punish you
we can hold you
very pretty good commitment but no lack
of people here that person isn't either
cuz they keep their keep moving around -
yeah
maybe we're just having submission
there's some people shuffling it's a
beta baby's doing baby there apparently
fighting no one oh yeah there's a sword
up there I love muscle yes this is
everything I wanted alright did you want
to join us try playing oh sure I'll give
it a shot it will get you after after
what I've - this I'm a good third
mashing akiko with a full beard nephal
got a little soul patch jack she does
got full beard still drinking that
protein has anyone here ever point gal
gun is it any good if you like on rail
shooters and what that games going for
you away can enjoy it it's Gallagher on
the one we're with the girls in the
school and you look so this story of gal
gun is you're playing as an angel who
sent to right the wrongs of a cupid
angel who's set pheromones out loose in
a school yes that is the same thing you
got to shoot them with Michaels and bear
the pheromone gun to make it so that
they don't jump at you hey I got in
finally
alright let's fight I'm here for the
fights I'm not the girl goes at least on
camera though I've played gerawan chair
at Gallagher and go to Giant Bomb calm a
good friend try to bring the coverage
here I'm trying to I'm try to let the
people know they got some real good gal
gun comes different stage
[Applause]
but who's this this is one handsome
no no character that's Catalina jelly
with black hair yeah that's what I'm
into
yeah can we know with their second color
is the best that's why my at the MCAS
arbonne international got ice card gooey
duck Celine
she's Orie and Jim Kisaragi one yeah
there's your uncle that's s that's s is
lolly from Bob plays blue so charlotta
got that same energy you got Bella does
a big story
I see all right I see you arches
[Music]
okay yeah I'm talking about that's
something I'm bill
I draw the line there's a line and I
Drive - Munna not engage apple juice
Sam dodge let me star athlete
[Music]
yeah
the pride boys love ourselves to trash
[Music]
I'm probably the worst out of this is
you got your first game that shirts your
gimme and then after that no jobs no
what no jobs like when people say no
John just like no no excuses okay all
right
sure cuz there's a guy who is named like
John who just oh my controller was not
the position of the moon was messed up
the Sun was in my I'm gonna make some
excuses right now which is just that I
don't know what's going on that's my
excuse my cassettes
yeah every time it's a beta it's like oh
I don't get it very rarely do betas like
you actually like mess around in like a
training mode yeah it's like I just
needed the opportunity to learn the
inputs I thought yeah I want to look at
a move list I want to be able to see
what I'm doing is endless oh hey command
list for Catalina all right I never mind
light wall I hope you son
so all of the abilities are on the right
bumper yeah you can do that for r1 so
okay well that was a poor Circle Square
doesn't even remember forward or dragon
punch so you do forward r1 or you could
do dragon punch motion how they even
show how it looks
yeah that's fine Jack I have no excuse
I'm actually just bad yeah frozen blade
that's totally Jin kiss Iraqis i scar
Brazilian yes so far we're digging this
game yeah I'm having a good time
that is also no that's or EA's forward
core circle for right
oh yeah yeah can you do a Hadouken in
this game JK enough bleeds a frost okay
this is your soup oh I'll do only tease
it they don't actually show the whole
thing yeah like there's a bashful finish
did the room have circleback annointed I
did saw astral finish got their art
style is so gorgeous and we need to play
guilty gear okay let's see let's like
guilty gear was more white like 2015
2014 2014 I sure did one there's
2014-2015 point is that is a while and
to this day they still have not no one
is like outmatched Arts is like through
the art style I my roommate just called
me and then actually picked it up and
took it out of my pocket
you hung up on me as soon as I realize
that's probably on the show Spencer yeah
get him on him should what's going on
dude what's the word Raven let's go
Tiny's down to jump need some room to I
guess you won't play guilty gear for
guilty denied evil right no no that just
off the main stage damn they probably
took it off a while ago after that that
crazy highlight though were the the one
guy like got up mid-round cuz he thought
he's mouth yes guilty gear dude that was
so good do you see that no it's a guy
who like got up on stage thinking he won
oh he's like yeah and everyone's like
dude what do you do is like in the
middle of grand finals like he thought
he'd won the match and the guy just went
in and full combat him all the way down
yeah is like didn't you think it was Oh
Inc I feel so bad for him yeah he got
just publicly humiliated in front of
answer that's unfortunate
but it was really entertaining to watch
yeah let me get into a fight I don't see
how bad I am
oh he's calling again should I answer no
maybe yeah I leave that time I run it by
you guys I want to be ruined sure go for
it okay do it what's up oh hell yeah oh
yeah definitely
oh don't
[Music]
it's a stack I hope you all are say hi
to that everyone on the stream by the
way
[Music]
[Laughter]
ticking calls live on livestream all
right cool sounds good yeah we'll do you
too bye everyone
Spencer Hayes is goodbye internet those
my roommate who's so soup I like that
ooh I was going to he wanted to buy me
alcohol compare they get the call that's
fine you don't want to he's good yeah
yeah I thought he was like trying to
play a joke on me but he's actually
calling me about a legitimate thing I
mean that'd be a Spencer moves they
really would call that joke
[Music]
I'm all out you know
I'm spent anymore sorry it is already
704 so we're planning to go on for
another yeah bummer that we've been not
being able to get into fight yeah I mean
that the that's just how it goes with
these things be like a couple a now yeah
I want to play though I'll recapturing
this now
damn I'll capture try and catch you
tomorrow same cuz uh Peter is saying
like we should probably try and capture
as well I thought about that well be
there also isn't much to capture no I
saw a good missing house from that too
we played some Mortal Kombat 2 little
while ago it was a good time yeah so I
literally boil combat - yeah yeah we got
a challenge to choke oh boy it's true I
know I really wish that that came with
us fight like even if chuckle boy is
like cha-cha go boy was like a pro and
just like whooped our ass like flawless
victory twice still I want to see that
happen to us Jonathan brings us some
sweet Intel if too many issues sometimes
we're starting the game is good okay so
if it gets to the point where we can't
get into a game we could just do a hard
reset
okay sure we got some time we got a
little bit of time yeah
oh wow the apple juice is I'll play you
guys in grand grand blue Fantasy Versus
do it we'll probably play this game when
it comes out when it comes out we'll def
guarantee it'll happen yeah and we won't
be any better than we are now is the
Asia American connection good
there's one way to find out well are you
over we did fight that one person
another consonants or try to find that
one person we could can with Japanese
characters in their name maybe the full
game will be better - who knows I mean
of course if I mean I'm sure we'll have
the game if you pick up the game we'll
be here we can do it it'd be great
we'll make wonderful memories together
playing video games online sick beans
man Oh sick I made it yeah hey I'm gonna
get my ass would let's get it Catalina
yeah kind of thing aw dog it's a
Catalina mirror match it is Skybound
protector let's go man
oran play some grand blue proper now
yeah it seems like it's really cool i
download on my browser but I'll have to
do it because I can't read Japanese in
victory believe in Ventura that's kind
of art yeah a little
in retrospect it still got nothing on
that it got retail
like if you're not riding West you've
never seen counters counter there's a
really good
[Music]
Rossy let's get you better got you so
much
yeah they're very just navigating
various corners there was so much damage
oh no
our online tools with
- I had to put my move list beforehand
this is mommy's moment this is hard to
compare it all every what you had to do
he knew what he was doing I still got my
ass whooped yeah I wasn't I kinda want a
rematch those are some close matches
although I could understand ferry being
mopey because she's got the like a lot
of range seem like a kid keel I could
keep awake here yeah I'm thinking about
that apple juice
[Music]
what apple juice Elfi apple juice let's
run it back Emma okay
no disappeared yeah all right you got
your wins that's penny is saying that
fairies are the place
yeah I'm not i i'm sure if maybe i spent
time looking at the move list i might
have a better understanding but yeah the
same while fight zane curious about the
story motor arcade mode or something
like that yeah and I'm curious to see
what kind of modes this game has I'm
sure there's probably some pretty cool
stuff they could do you know I you know
what I didn't realize until recently huh
is that their arcade machines in the
overworld four blades book cross act she
can't do any love yeah how as if there
was like supposed to be an arcade mode
yeah I don't even noticed that
yeah but regardless whoa chuckle boy the
movie has little watch I'll watch it our
heroine savior chuckle boy the chat
really wants to find checkerboard I know
they're all trying to draw up this
rivalry hey I'm doubt it I just wish the
game would let us fight beyond anymore
they were like hey mate guys have fun
yeah good and then they haven't
responded it's still here I've left it's
a very same let's go dude I play a grand
blue RPG where you build your own
character like oh yeah it'd be real cool
job well says I want a hunter x hunter
or Fairy Tail fighting game well you
have hunter x hunter in jump forest
rubadoux's horse yeah
all rights on a recent I've like only
started hearing about that I've got you
I think it's been around for a while
okay I haven't watched it I only know
because it's been in like every other
like shown in crossover game but I want
want a Jojo fighting game go on Gintama
yahooza can come I give me a Gintama
fighting game I just want carry you in
something yeah that's who I want carry
you in a fighting game we thought Tekken
but then we thought wrong I was at the
the verge of begging to be like put him
in dinner alive at least like yeah he'd
work there I don't want to do that but
he don't worry looks like we're having
problems connecting with Zane over there
uh Bob any Ultima if you want to fight
you can allow that comment yeah
definitely yeah like a like a Jojo
fighting game done by Hearts us again
but in this game Jojo fighting game yeah
they did the the one that was pretty
good the one that was like kind of based
off the street fighter for engine yeah
Benny do you want by Cowboy Bebop
third-person shooter games hear me out
whoa more cowboy bebop beam up
oh dude what if our GG did a cowboy
bebop game that would be the better way
I think that's the way to go is side
quest dialogue style you got the music
the soundtrack spike Spiegel running
around I think I think that would be the
way to do it dude that's the thing about
kattiline after the
Fist of the North Star game they did
yeah I kind of realized like the gaw
cruz' formula works really well for
anime editions and uh our boy Jacob man
who does the PR for first Sega wouldn't
ask me and Matt as Spinelli like if
y'all could do yuccas a style game for
any other any other property Luigi would
you watch it I was like Naruto he's I'm
a [ __ ] dumbass Matt was just like
I'll go north star this is where it's at
or Jojo seems you shouldn't say cowboy
could happen I'll talk to you got Jojo
was in jump horse John walked and get
what but Betty ultimate right now judge
order of Cujo and not deal brandy with
the steel sucks
first whoa I love Joe Jenn and John Luke
investigating my favorite James Potter
boy look investigating a bent Benny's
back flip they get the run back
don't let the love that person take you
see
[Music]
real human being
oh man we've done it did did did y'all
get to see the the win cuz of course
it's the first thing you've got to ask
Josh Blackwell says there's echo I'm
orange it says echo echo echo the
dolphin okay can you hear an echo with
us Michelle let us let us know okay man
I just want to ask did you all see that
win or not yes
yeah sorry about that guys that was our
one with a suit blue our are with our a
device in the back it just stopped
stopped I just had to hit it again so go
back and kick the thing also oh there is
an echo oh shoot there's an icon it's
the secret door
maybe maybe the streams up in a window
maybe
oh yeah okay all right we should be good
now the extreme that I was doing a check
to make sure this dream was working
let's get yes I would love another apple
juice for ballet another 15 minutes so
yeah now I'm good good what are we doing
a game spot I don't know playing games I
mean where you are the spot for games
after all so while if for those who have
just tuned in and aren't sure what we're
doing because we're waiting to connect
to these games betting Ultimo you want
to go for another round you won't go for
another round let's go let's go Oh Betty
Olsen was putting up some good matches
it's true we are playing granblue
fantasy versus closed public beta
Grambling fantasy is a mobile RPG some
bubble got you think sure yeah but this
is a fighting game version of it made by
Arc System Works who you may have heard
of who made dragon ball fighters who
made BlazBlue who made guilty gear they
have they are working on a grand blue of
fantasy fighting game which we have here
and we're trying to test it out yeah
let's see what's I need to stop moving
that on the table yeah yeah
Leslie asks would we buy a Kardashian
vs. games a little fame about family
members in it only for we're an anime
fighter yes in this style in this style
yeah I mean arcs is can make any word I
guess sure just put it through the arcs
is filter
man what if just got the rights like
Street Fighter capcom said hey officers
won't you make us free fire six you'd
finally get a good street fighter after
that has messed up true fighter 5 isn't
great
it's it's alright bleach fighting game
uh I haven't watched my splits I'm not
very attached to a ball you have jump
for it that's true but that's not gonna
keep saying for like trust me I want to
fight again for like all these dope
anime but I'm gonna be like yeah don't
give it a game Oaks really gross alright
I feel like thinking might be better
after our style we're just not what it
is at all yeah ourselves off-putting
alleys for me oh yeah I don't we got a
Catalina Muir match again cuz apparently
she is a best girl
do I agree she's got belts belts for
jungles for days yeah that's how you
know she anime she's got Biltz welcome
Sora Sora ain't got nothing on Catalina
there you go
neither does hide hi Kai belts
[Music]
believe in victory believe in victory
engage
all right there you go tell ya let's go
left
hell yeah Jonah get to that sing my man
you're left it's boy Oh perfect
oh my manager left to then it's perfect
the moment dlc confirmed where is Johnny
investigates chomik investigates as much
this is good mad Ravens putting up a
fight
that took about one buddy what's MI
he cuddly Oh
which character action games football
plans I go is exciting that we're fine
yeah my super persona she got that stand
action
just saw murder happened by somebody
sure there's good [ __ ] Raven hey I like
that hi I like that actually I don't
think what happened time I would
actually not mind a full Ruby only
resilient yeah in the 3d style because I
because then show is yeah yeah why it
makes sense right it would translate
extremely wise and that shows like a keg
of our oh yeah
working class you know oh Ravens picking
this policy is no perfect people
let that town back are you playing
keep-away
[Music]
Ross soon all right good match I took
round one but why not me
now we got noodle oh my muscles are in
my my legs I used to be small that I'm
not then I wasn't I got I got flippin
powerful advice so here can we fight him
Kenny would tell us where sonic Fox he's
in he's in the New York servers
I saw excite people his livestream real
quick it's on someone in the chat tell
us what server are we actually gonna VIN
I would love to fight saw my phone
you've had enough apple juice to one
hunt down sonic Fox he's in the New York
servers so we got us we got a switch
that's fine we can search it sweet job
how do you do that
leave Lobby well so cat tell us which
server in our living let me peep his
livestream real quick night cuz sonic
box represent dude decimal boy [ __ ] is
the hero we all need he'll save us I'll
see
it's the plane
it's going to extreme so we've got that
name so maybe he'll be like odds
gamespot they want to try to and try to
go to probably I I'm wrestling GameSpot
edition with the strong staff hey there
is some there's some pretty strong
people here there are it's very very
true if I could arm wrestle with my lot
of tall people here there are a lot of
tall people very intimidating even match
right now so I can't I can't see ya way
we can we get like half prepared for it
yeah let's do that we gonna be full love
muscle you wanna meet that I wanna know
you know love muscle want to try but
Stuart let's do a match and then well
you know if we can find the opportunity
[Music]
wanna go for it all right see I
guarantee it's cool it is for an ollie
luck
[Music]
and do you alright yeah I am
thank you sir sit back off New York in
work lobby night
oh yeah duh I tried it I mean I'm a
lowly
nothing we just gonna sit here and wait
yeah but to lose huh yeah
and we're in overtime right now this is
this is whatever triplex will caliber
six online it's pretty dead oh it's hmm
rough tire I really like some caliber
Ali thank you know up do very has an alt
skin that looks like Blake yeah sup
y'all we've made it you picked the the
lobby next here we are in New York you
might have words connection though and
we've also make the test we're doing our
part in testing out the cameras of
course now we're trying to see we're
testing the network stress have more
I've been keeping up with the DLC stuff
outside of the probe to be the put the
lolita girl in there a me rabbit monkey
with with the heavy questions right oh
shoot that's a dude that's a whole
street hot top ten is a lot to that's a
lot because like three just for the sake
of us being here I mean do we are we
talking anime proper are we talking to
anime jacent anime property property
animation proper okay who wants to jump
in first we do like one than one than
one I mean so does anime proper also
encompass persona because as there is an
anime adaptation arc is that that would
be cheating though because like my top
ten would just be are they are the
gurney anime though
but are they as good the enemy is there
in the game well the characters are as
good as they are in the anime but the
anime doesn't got take the anime an
anime face Valley yeah you got you got a
look at just as the Anna man cuz like a
lot of anime is based on manga but I
would say like the anime itself yeah
like I for the purposes of this I'm just
gonna exclude okay GA we say Yukari
right I think it because what my
favourite animes is uh full metal
yeah and I'd be like oh what care
what's the best person from we're all
overthinking there's a lot to choose no
there's no this this is important
business I mean I can start Armstrong as
a bowline I got a good idea for my
number ok ok give me a communist from oh
mama girl lucky girl loggin yeah oh yeah
communist one if i had of the chance
coming sorry I had a friend in college
who is like obsessed card
like that's fair it's a pretty good one
a clown fight with like the fool like
like the Cape in the glasses why he had
the glasses on the regular and one time
you want him with the cave I don't like
dude I please tell me that he just
yelled like random quotes like do you
know that oh yeah yeah yes wow that's so
doing he was a good man all right so
I've done my number one it can go either
it to either you guys now Naruto boruto
and Sasuke I'm just kidding probably I
wouldn't order them in particularly but
definitely one of my top three is
Kakashi from naughty school Kakashi's
dope he's the guard ammaji
goro majima and armstrong for hole metal
oh nice he's great how can you not like
I'm strong yeah he's a cool big tall guy
even up late you've not watched full
metal then no I haven't seen full metal
yet you cuz cuz if you watch full metal
you would know who I'm talking about
Oh Ram & mugeez come on man look you got
you got put me on the spot I'm putting
you on the spot yeah well this is the
thing though if it's calling out of
kameena I am NOT even upset because this
legitimate like I'm fine I'll pick one
that's not generic my number two is
ginto key off of Gotama yeah yeah I like
kintoki he's great a garter belt from
panning sake oh hell yeah I'll go with a
real left-field track there I should
have a PSG character on my top three
what some EVPs you so good I'm gonna
manage take a book blu-ray of that
have you do the summer dub so eat the
great thing about watching PSG sub or
dubbed is that it's a different
experience both ways really is because
it's an online degree the the double V a
kind if we're just like let's get a
general idea of what's happening and
then do a victory you have different
jokes different setups like completely
different jokes yeah paper on way home
where yes which you think would be badly
funnier yeah
stop very good yes G yeah after you guys
have never seen PSG use is probably can
you come in with the truth just saying
your name your name is a fantastic anime
me don't you want to try to man
find yourself a champion
they go home bring someone you care
about you wash that it'll bring you
closer
you'll care about each other fantastic
I also agree with the general statement
it's blocking blah blah I'm gonna punish
Oh
[Music]
is final fantasy apparently cuz he's
summoned Mohammed you're a terrible dead
now if I'm gonna get my ass beat I want
to get my ass beaten style
let's see some cool [ __ ] go down yeah
that's cool thank you for whooping my
ass they chose what was I say Oh Emmy
Yusef from Devils a part-timer
top three oh macha no from a Killa kill
oh yeah I'm flipping you know I'll go
the [ __ ] home opposite when I come back
out [ __ ] up Marcos very good but
flipping I'm a monkey that's what I hear
cure Ewing and her awesome eyebrows yeah
sots keys eyebrows are good they are the
top ten
yes Otzi's eyebrows killa kill is
different so good yeah
Mako's good do is the best wife no phone
7:30 but why don't we do another fighter
- we're close it out yeah I think I'm
doing the run back with uh I mean I've
still got you still got apple juice left
to my zoo I just want to seal a shalls'
to do some suits some super super moves
on me again
whoa I chose these chairs make some
really good sounds talk about a
nightmare
riding Catalina another top for the
anime character bad yeah oh yeah Corey
from Kourtney comes Wow coach Z yep
yeah cookies they push me in the future
I want to replay a lot of strong on a
homestar runner no but it's got to be
overdone in super anime look at what oh
but there is that one wrong cat am a
version that's yeah yeah that's a
strongman email right yeah we're good
those like an anime version of him yes I
mean like strong guy turns into like
Mega Man or Sanjay no I think he has
like a really big went for like the
whole Japanese like bad Japanese you go
shows in practicing
[Music]
wow that's so good they are well how
about it that's the most like realistic
end of the fight like thing I think I've
seen you know fighting game in a while
it's just like a yeah everyone's like oh
you ain't [ __ ] see rampant agree
scouring the houses most Opie anime
character ever made sure let's see who
else would be in my top three what if I
watched recent man uh Joe Cole in ER I
know yoga Lesnar's in your top yes yo-yo
goes on my desk and no one's hauled me
away it's Oh Yoko Lintner and and calm
you know are both a new top three what
happened to the screen connect still
can't join let's get one more yeah let's
go one more let's go let's go back to LA
home home turf
Leonardo dojinshi is my favorite
[Music]
Danny Vegeta Danny Bushido is my
favorite Dragon Ball character uh
whippin sauce guy
youichi ha is my favorite huh Jason
Jason Naruto and Sasuke
Jason Naruto Golani Kenshin is my
favorite would you say that one all the
time I do it's my my go-to
[Music]
uh Kyle Qatar I'm so sorry that we're
such a mess pocket cards are pretty cool
anime character somewhat damn this will
have got tucked my seat jazzy's real
quick yeah there you go dudes going off
on tangent I love those old dark forces
games oh yeah
Jedi Knight dark forces dudn't
especially where I had like the FMV like
live-action yeah ah Kyle Katarn Oh about
that
yeah Jedi Outcast lik Jedi Academy live
we should play some Jedi Academy or
something oh sure those were like can
you for the first games I ever played
that's terrible I because it was like
fine it was really hard to figure out
why lightsaber combat ya know those
games are really tough and then I was on
top of that like four or five so good
news I've just learned that my house is
completely forces it always does our and
a half trying to get one more fighters
[Music]
so we've been doing that Ken I'm sorry
hey have I been burping I apologize I'm
pretty sure I have I hope I happen can
you guys burp on commands did you get on
command know when I'd really when I do
it's pretty good so I feel like pretty
good so I can I can burp anytime I can
do that's weird
which were weird yeah
cuz like it's like one of those things
like people like stamping your fingers
learning to burp on command like doing
all that I could not so I can now snap
with this I said Oh can't no I can't do
that yeah this one's kind of lame but I
can still do it
I can't it's like there's nothing
nothing there Kumasi shoe or your thanos
and you had your bad hand for snap like
oh [ __ ] I can't I can't hold on just
wait a minute wait for it
vanos there it is top 10 anime character
right there Danis yeah I know we've been
talking about burps and I feel like
there's a burp like right on the verge
man trying to connect with us we're
sorry for snapping to the microphone
yeah I thought about that I hope that
yeah y'all are like loudest [ __ ]
ignorant
well Landon good to see you trying to
find a fight I'm trying to look for a
sword that's not crossed all these folks
across faiths can't escape from crossing
swords can't escape from trying to find
if I'd like to get at least one more
magic yeah we got twitch name oh oh sub
Joe slurper toast loafer that's a joke
it's toe where is 2019 we're out here
slurping toes that's a good I love that
that is a bad name but let's get it dude
I love people
Gary or in their like their company
names right yeah who the [ __ ] puts our
Chloe dnews well for stream is fine
we're stirring for I we're getting in
this match now dude we got changed it to
twitch later to youtube.com forward
slash random number slash live slash
games but I know if you do live GameSpot
slash life it'll bring it to this sure
alright toe slur dude this is the
perfect match to end it this is the
perfect match to send us off in your
weekend oh yeah I guess
[Applause]
Wow supers that's what we're doing here
to Johnson says they're gonna close
Oh gross John is 2019
you're right I shouldn't shame homes I
oughta win these next two matches scores
over for me it's over for your toes
you're a rock poster the freezing Ross
moving some rods were consecrated
Bueller's and Winkies
Oh
what do you want extreme damn dude do
you want one more
you want one more all up the run bad you
want the run back alright guys let's get
the run back I'll call it it's right
like I said I can't feel my ass so I'm
set alright cool
I'm sure at some point I can ask a
message maybe like where the heck are
you and then you just wink the stream oh
she's probably watching action oh man
she said she wanted to all right like
she's probably be like dude get off what
the heck are you doing this is work but
apparently I'm turning up when I get
home so all cuz I Spencer hooked you up
with with the good good yeah they went
to the there's this place that's been
described to me as like the the play
place of liquor buying whoa it's got
like I don't know like a like there's
like tubes and stuff in climb around in
it's like look at Chuck E Cheese but you
buy alcohol so it's like oh Dave &
Buster's yeah but he but he's like oh we
went and so when it was my birthday he
got this shot from the bartender and the
dudes like Costas forever like distilled
ancient thing from the mountains that we
can only get like three times a year
Buddhist monks yeah [ __ ] I couldn't fill
up themselves all right let's go akela
but you found it and he's like hey you
want me to pick it up it tastes like
Gatorade like spicy Gatorade whoa that's
pretty good yeah like dude Gatorade with
with some Tajin so yeah like the Mexican
spices I used to eat back home yeah so I
was like hell yeah dude pick that up
he's like it's a grip though I'm like
get it anyway it's good like mixer cuz I
have a bunch of liquor home and I have
some Gatorade the liquor Palatka but
like I don't do it whiskey or anything
no definitely not whiskey I also get
like a vodka like a jam yeah probably
like my Eugene kiss ragi yeah
I couldn't look at either of you when I
said it so all right I couldn't get the
run back on toast with her fur because
deaf will dipped out it's like I got my
toast ler I'm different
so like their toes to slur yeah I wanted
to see at least one more match because
I'm feeling yeah I'm good about the same
I'm really feeling it oh right like this
is why we subscribed game salt well I
mean I'm glad that this is a thing this
is this only happens once in a blue moon
yeah so what's in it what's it uh I mean
I mean if we wanted to we really could
probably not for the next two weeks
though because XIII is about the hit
Betty this is my chance to sell out real
quick hold on yeah if you guys want to
stay tuned to the coolest and happen in
this place for all of your III content
and say it please stay here subscribe to
our channel we'll have round-the-clock
coverage constant videos being uploaded
impressions from people like us for
people like you
we're actually doing a lot of dope stuff
for e3 Real Talk so stick around for
that I know we probably got all the
delinquents in the chat like us you know
I'm saying out here for the enemy
fighters late night on a Friday but you
know what I'm saying
stick the game spot cuz we have so many
good people working on so much great
stuff especially when III rolls around
we're seeing so many exclusive and not
exclusive but like we're seeing so many
games that haven't even come out yet and
we're getting a like set impressions and
like in-depth analysis and all that
stuff so we don't just [ __ ] around
on here we like to have fun but we also
do a lot of work so stick around for
that
yeah also I'm trying to get damn
fighting Bob
yes that was my quick quick selling
moment thank you you know that's gonna
be we can't survive without y'all we're
gonna be doing some regular streams next
week got about us specifically big game
spot we doing some regular streams next
week but we do have I know we're gonna
be covering goop stadia I believe
there's there's probably some silly
covering yay
who's gonna Saturday's there's gonna be
some Microsoft Microsoft some Sundays
all the way up until Tuesday when III
officially start something we have our
like all based release that we're gonna
be doing
so Monday sorry Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday I'm like seems like a lemon too
like this lost it's late it's a lot yeah
we do I I direct those and yeah
I can't you know obvious I can't say
anything but I looked a little bit at
some of the guests got some exciting
stuff we feel Spencer ring the chat here
tonight I'm sayin there's some cool
stuff that I'm looking forward to seeing
are you the Phil Spector yeah I am
whoa look at this cause this is the
sauce guy of this is the sauce guy I
don't get to go actually like that to a
point because I have to break the state
show I do get to watch all the stage
show and like I'm actually really sir
Ansel I've
Wow speaking of what really stuck I
don't see people people saying that
sound like
breaking up let's go oh [ __ ] you got
going just he's a drug boy or something
yeah yeah
to engage cuz that's all
[Music]
real life I'm Edward Snowden thank you
Michael
yeah I was like I was looking at I'm
definitely not sorry oh oh we get my ass
up
I got that's cuz the chance gone dang
dude damn it I can't believe let Sasuke
beat me oh that was fun though that's
fun my comments everyone's nicely in
this game
yeah it's friendly matches alright we've
gone on way too long we need to stop all
right can you stop ourselves good moves
Oregon loose good Matt apple juice all
right that was
we played a lot more granblue Fantasy
Versus closed public beta than you felt
good but yeah that was a long all right
so first off I want to thank all of you
out there for watching chill with us and
some of y'all who actually joined in and
found us in the lobbies to get some
matches in we appreciate all that it's
so much fun to play with all of you and
it's so much fun to play these games
because we love ourselves some anime
fighters in thank you also to chat for
entertaining us with all of your all
adapt militias so you know I'm saying
like we're we really appreciated that so
Ben you got any words to say before I
close this out don't be a fool stay in
school play yakisoba play danganronpa
follow the channel so we can hang out
with your whole bunch yeah thank you to
John Luke site key yes our boy who is
running the stream but also hopping onto
the stream with us at the same time we
created we appreciate all the work that
he does and again thank you all for
hanging out with us we was playing
granblue Fantasy Versus closed beta so
if you like what you see keep an eye on
that and also keep an eye on us at
GameSpot cuz we're here to have fun and
let y'all know what's happening in the
games industry so peace out have a good
weekend bye there's no explosion where's
the explosion where's the explosion
[Music]